it's how are you Sammy yeah you know I'm
doing fine how are you doing you're 5
and 3 i'm doing pretty good yeah your
bills are five and three Oh Sammy what
was that like for you yesterday with a
big division win on the road first one
of your career with the Buffalo Bills I
was a great run for the TV for the
program um I mean we went down there and
play good idea to play well the offers
play well we took in the ball and I'm
you know we've gotta get on this by we
can get back and start start buying
again yep and at five and three right
now Sammy as we're watching you run for
the touchdown to put the team over the
40-point mark yesterday watching the
defense put you back on the field over
and over and over again in the first
quarter with all of those interceptions
what was that like from your perspective
sammie rhodes great is just knowing that
I difference where the high level and
audition people out three and now is
getting all the interception stacks and
fumbles that's what we need defense wins
championships and win games and a five
defense key behind and we keep scoring
20 and 30 and 40 points we're going to
be a great team and what is kyle orton
brought to this offense for you um i
would def to say leadership he leads the
scenes through adversity into the good
times and I either he's definitely one
of our biggest critic on the field
hospital and uh he's been exceptional
with his keeping his poise in the game
Sammy Watkins of the Buffalo Bills
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
and Sammy I do have to bring up with you
I'm sure you knew I would bring this up
somebody in my position here you having
a seeming touchdown in your grasp
yesterday and being caught from behind
inside the 5-yard line what happened
there Sammy Watkins he's been idiot
really uh I thought I had them about
five yards and I look at the jump on but
I guess my heart planet racing much
closer than that one or two yard
I me and I went to celebrate and I he
basically was finishing the place he was
always booked on attacking that 25 dolla
what did your coach say to you when you
came off the field after that one I'm
just gonna make that mistake in here and
I'll just finished playing uh next time
i got the bosses what and did you hear
from anybody after the game anybody that
sort of took you to task also anybody
send your txt to voice mail or tweet
anything Sammy of course my whole family
basically a llamar o my dad my
girlfriend just about everybody I know
Lauren kind of wood throughout my life
they def see gave me a text and you see
Twitter fantasy points so I dev I'm
definitely where my mistake yeah team
Watkins is doesn't want these they're
your safety net Sammy we can't have you
checking out Jumbotrons going to the end
zone and when you when you could score
touchdown Sammy right yeah I know next
time I other singles that played most a
few nobody would watch pinching their
brains on you I know and plus now you
are the standard bearer of the week to
week Player of the Week award here my
mom this is this is something my mom
even very little that she knows about
football would take issue with Sammy the
certificates coming your way and I'm
just wondering if if you wouldn't mind
putting it in your locker this would
mean a lot to my mother not just this
show Sammy that possible for you to do
that oh yeah okay so we're gonna be able
to see this award in your locker and and
this and again you can enjoy this on
your bye week you can take it around I
mean I'm sure it'll get you in
restaurants if you need you know this
will work for you Sammy oh yeah it'll be
a nice gift ok thank you very much Sammy
Watkins I appreciate you calling in to
the to the show and good luck moving
forward five and three so far in your
rookie season thank you a lot for have
known so you bet that Sammy Watkins here
of the Buffalo Bills the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience
you